Now let's talk about measuring performance. We have seen
that we can express performance as 1 over execution time.
But the execution time is on what workload? So if
we want to measure performance on two machines and compare them,
the question is, what do we run on them to
tell which on is faster than the other, and by
how much. The best assessment of how do they compare,
is if we run actual workloads from a particular user.
But, this requires us to run many different programs, what
we get is not representative of other users who might
be using this machine completely differently, and there is the
question of how do we get the workload data? Even if
we found the user who's usage patterns are representative of
many others, how do we persuade that person to give us
exactly what they were doing with the machine over a
course of, let's say, a day? So when we compare performance
of different machines, we usually don't do
this, instead, we use so-called benchmark workloads.